[Music]  Janet Jackson took to the stage for her  first post-baby show and her snapback  game was strong its classic me with a  modern twist the pop superstar kicked  off her state of the world tour in  Louisiana on Thursday 51 year old Janet  showed off her incredible weight loss in  a series of skin-tight ensembles on  stage  [Music]  she gave us Rhythm Nation vibe showing  off her slim down figure in a black  curve hugging jumpsuits then she pulls  out her best dance moves in a white  sweater jeans and knee-high boots safe  to say Janet is one hot mama her  post-pregnancy body is unreal since  welcoming her son Issa  back in January my family means  everything a source told ET back in  August Janet worked hard to get into  performance shape quote she has lost  more than 65 pounds and has her pre-baby  body back and then some  [Music]